[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show the bench bureau show is sponsored
by expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
slash been a horrifying day for the
united states as 12 u.s marines are dead
that number is likely to increase over
the course of the next 24 hours because
many more are wounded overall the
terrorist attacks in kabul today have
resulted in at least 60 deaths and 140
wounded many of those people are of
course american soldiers and service
members joining us on the line to
discuss brigadier general blaine holt
retired us air force brigadier general
was a former c-17 combat commander and
u.s deputy military representative to
nato regular general thanks so much for
joining the show appreciate it really
rough day obviously
it is thanks for having me back then so
let's talk about what's going on on the
ground uh have you been in touch with
anybody who's on the ground at the
airport at this point
i have been on the touch uh in touch
with several who have been working the
situation on the ground it's uh it's
absolutely chaos as you might imagine so
can you give us the latest on and what
is the sort of breakdown what is the
security situation like over there um
you know are they expecting more
terrorist attacks in the near future
here
yeah i think they have to they've been
certainly told to be aware that more are
on the way um
so far from the sources i have on the
ground we've got three suicide bombers i
know that two are being reported but
there were three
um that i know of
they hit a gate
and a hotel where americans were being
collected my understanding was there's
quite a population between those two
that are very tightly packed in together
and uh the the
carnage that's on the ground including
our fallen uh marines
and uh and navy uh uh colleague uh is is
it's it's just it's it's incredible uh
at the same time we have seen that some
of the aircraft have been taking small
arms fire out of the field as they have
either dispersed or taken off out of
kabul and the mission goes on we we have
heard of some extractions by special
operations forces but obviously not
anything robust and there's still
a very grave security situation there
kabul the commanders certainly have
their hands full what i can say is is
that our service men and women are
performing uh well beyond expectations
that anybody could have for them in this
kind of environment it is a fundamental
betrayal of men and women in the
american military to put them in
positions where they are likely to be in
this sort of situation we're speaking
with brigadier general retired blaine
holt um so general when when we talk
about the situation on the ground at
kabul airport maybe you can draw a
picture a little bit for us of what the
geography of kabul airport is like so
when we hear that i think most americans
think of lax or they think of kennedy
they think of these vast panoramic
airports with tons of runways
and various entry points
what is kabul airport actually like
so kabul is very small and it's all
packed in with a lot of wide body
aircraft there is
a ring road that goes around the field
it's got about seven gates um
but it's it's very very difficult to
defend because it's porous um our you
know we've got a lot of people on the
ground there to do airfield defense but
um you could you can easily see where
those seven entry points uh you could
pack in a crowd telling who's who and
and sorting out a terrorist from someone
who's not a terrorist is very difficult
exercise they did have warnings
overnight that there was going to be
something imminent coming to the field
they took those seriously and we were
all questioning wow we're not asking
people to come to the airport well this
is this is the reason why that was well
one of the things that we learned today
from the head of centcom general kenneth
mckenzie is that we have been using the
taliban to provide essentially security
and screening at the airport that we
were using them to actually
push
sort of pat people down make sure they
they were the new tsa was the taliban
and so we have obviously an excellent
history with the taliban in having them
fight terrorism the last time we asked
them to fight terrorism they took down
the world trade center attacked the
pentagon uh and uh and brought down a
plane in in pennsylvania or at least
provided cover to al-qaeda to do so and
then refused to turn al-qaeda over so
they have a great job they've done a
great job historically of preventing
terrorism we are now heavily reliant on
the taliban uh the the head of centcom
said today that he is honestly not sure
as to whether the taliban did this by
accident or whether they just let the
isis suicide bombers right on through
and yet we continue to rely on the
taliban to quote unquote provide
security
yeah no that this is going to get looked
at
for years after this is over but one of
the things that uh we have seen in the
past four days and this is not by any
stretch of the imagination concurrence
with how this is gone
it is that
the taliban have insisted that they are
able to block points checkpoints
and the situation with this evacuation
that we found ourselves in they have
actually provided some security at the
gates in their own best interest not the
united states best interest that's a key
difference here because
for the taliban to take the country back
they don't want to see things like this
happen on our exit because then then it
doesn't go in the in the method that
they wanted that isis is their enemy as
well and it makes us wonder whether
they've got control of anything would
taliban let somebody through
who knows but what i can say is is
you're absolutely right to question
whether it's wise to have any kind of
relationship with them or put ourselves
into a position to have a relationship
with them on something as uh as key as
this with so many people still left to
be saved so speaking of that obviously
this entire effort was designed in order
to extract americans from kabul
at this point we are hearing that there
are over a thousand american citizens
who are left in kabul uh the number of
citizens plus green card holders is way
larger than that and the number of
afghan citizens we've basically left for
dead there is hundreds of thousands i
mean there's just no question that tens
of thousands of people are going to be
slaughtered at the hands of the taliban
at this point and not only that we're
now learning from politico that our wise
leaders decided that an excellent idea
would be to actually hand a list of the
people who wanted to evacuate over to
the taliban so they could facilitate the
security we handed them a list of all
the people the afghans were applying for
special immigrant visas the american
citizens the green card holders so the
taliban now have a complete list of all
the people we were attempting to
evacuate
it boggles the mind
yeah and we we
from the ground we heard reports of the
taliban coming on to kabul and basically
redlining people off of flights that we
have siv status that that had a clear
ticket out i'm working in particular uh
with a family to try to facilitate this
family that was 600 feet from their
freedom
uh to with papers to get on an airplane
to go to a european country and the
taliban intervened and now they're
they're they're fleeing for their lives
trying to get to a land-based border and
these are you know three kids and a mom
and a dad and their their big crime is
uh supporting a christian charity in the
country that was doing humanitarian work
uh this is this is absolutely horrible
and then we talk about just kabul the
one thing that i want to expand the
conversation out is there's 33 provinces
and there's people all over the country
and we're getting reports on the ground
of horrific events that the taliban
which is trying to repackage itself into
this oh we've we've changed no no no
that's not what's happening in the 33
provinces they are
uh raping and killing women they're
hanging police officers who uh we're
trying to keep order they're running
around with loudspeakers uh calling for
people that they're looking for and
what's going to happen after we are gone
and the lights go out in afghanistan and
they can't see internet we can't see
them uh
what will happen then and uh and so this
you know i i've said this this is as bad
as we could see 20 years of war ending
up i'm speaking with brigadier general
retired blaine holt uh so general uh
we've heard from members of the pentagon
that we are in fact going to pursue the
people who pursued the terrorist attack
today what capacity do we actually have
to do that considering that we basically
have no eyes and ears anywhere outside
of kabul international airport at this
point and our military is essentially
restricted to kabul international
airport so what capacity do we actually
have to to perform those sorts of
operations right now
yep so so there's methodologies that i
can't talk about but i will tell you
that it may not be today and it may not
be tomorrow but but we have the ability
to hold any target on the globe at risk
24 7 365. we
we if we have the will
uh we will not let this pass and i would
urge military uh leaders and civilian
leaders uh to strongly pursue the course
of action if that that if that's what
they say they are going to do then they
should do that
brigadier general retired blaine hall
really appreciate your time on this
terrible day and of course please convey
our our best and uh and all of our
support to the people who are on the
ground that you're talking to right now
absolutely will and i will tell you that
in our country there are 17 million
veterans ben we are all watching this
many of us served in afghanistan we are
absolutely jaws open and despondent and
we wish that we were with our crews and
our ground forces now i can tell you on
october 7th on the 20th anniversary of
oef
we're calling for as many vets as
possible to meet us all at the lincoln
memorial to reaffirm
our oath to the constitution that has no
expiration
and to basically reconnect with our
nation and to pray for our fallen and
our wounded well that is again brigadier
general retired blaine holt appreciate
the time sir alrighty in just one second
we're going to bring you a reminder of
the timeline here of mistakes by the
biden administration like how this thing
actually unfolded in real time because
you'll hear all the lies stacked on top
of the lies first
you know sleeping is not easy these days
considering the terrible situation in
which we all find ourselves as americans
but if you are going to attempt to bed
down for the night you at least need to
sleep on a mattress that is made for you
i mean everything in your life is
personalized so why wouldn't you
take the helix sleep quiz helix sleep
built a quiz it takes two minutes to
complete they use the answers to match
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you if you like
a mattress that's really soft or firm if
you sleep on your side or your back or
your stomach if you sleep really hot
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and everybody's unique taste
like me just go to helixsleep.com
shapiro they will match you to a
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life i sleep on a helix mattress
you don't need to take my word for it
helix is rated best mattress of 2019 by
both gq and wired magazine everything is
made right here in america they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights at risk free if you try
helix and you don't like it they'll pick
it up right for you no problem right now
helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars off your mattress order up to
200 bucks off at helixsleep.com
shapiro again your sleep quality depends
on you having a mattress made just for
you helix sleep did that for me and the
wife and man it is a great mattress go
check them out right now helix sleep.com
shapiro for up to 200 off alrighty so i
just want to take on a brief tour down
memory lane so that you can recall
what a disaster this administration has
allowed to unfold
so here is the timeline okay april 14th
of this year joe biden announced that we
would be leaving
he said we'd be leaving by september
11th
and uh and he said that we definitely
would not conduct a hasty rush to the
exit he said we would do it responsibly
i ask you whether that's true or not
we'll not conduct a hasty rush to the
exit
we'll do it we'll do it responsibly
deliberately and safely
and we will do it
in full coordination with our allies and
partners
who now have more forces in afghanistan
than we do
and the taliban should know that if they
attack us as we draw down we will defend
ourselves and our partners with all the
tools at our disposal
well was any of that true was any of
that true not a word of it was true not
one iota of that was true because the
president of the united states is a
damned liar he's a damned liar we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first if you haven't refined your
mortgage like if you haven't looked at
doing that recently you really should
the simple fact of the matter is
that mortgage rates are at historic lows
right now your biggest monthly bill is
indeed your mortgage it takes just a
10-minute call to american financing
america's home for home loans to get
your mortgage taken a look at take
advantage of a free loan review from a
salary based mortgage consultant meaning
no pressure no obligation no upfront or
hidden fees just a simple conversation
around which program can fit your budget
better because rates are still near
all-time lows and there's a good chance
you can benefit without adding years to
your loan that's correct you can choose
any term 10 years and over so you're not
wasting money on years you don't need so
what exactly are you waiting for you can
pre-qualify for free and you may be able
to postpone two payments when you call
866-721-3300
3300 or visit americanfinancing.net
nmls18234 nmls consumer access dot or go
check them out eight six six seven two
one thirty three hundred you can get
that monthly mortgage below or why
wouldn't you take the opportunity to
refi go check out my friends at
americanfinancing.net or give them a
call at
866-721-3300 already coming up the
disaster continues to unfold in
afghanistan we'll bring you the latest
plus we'll take you on a walk down
memory lane with president joe biden as
the bench bureau show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show so given the fact that we are
currently experiencing more casualties
in afghanistan than we have in years
i think it is worthwhile at this point
to point out what joe biden said was
going to happen here so first on april
14th of this year he said that we would
not conduct a hasty rush to the exit
we'd do it reasonably and responsibly
and in coordination with our allies
every word of that was a lie
then on july 8th you will recall that
joe biden said this was not in any way
like saigon this would not be like
vietnam he was right it's not like
saigon it is way worse than saigon
and the number of american troops who
died during the withdrawal from saigon
itself was zero the number of american
troops who have died now
in afghanistan is 12
as of right now
we also didn't leave a bunch of american
citizens behind in saigon we are leaving
over a thousand american citizens behind
in kabul
we are leaving green card holders
thousands of them behind in kabul
we are abandoning all of our allies the
same way we did in vietnam
also quick reminder the vietcong didn't
actually attack the united states
homeland or provide harbor to people who
did when we started the vietnam war
we are now turning back the entire
country of afghanistan over to a bunch
of eighth century barbarian goat herders
armed now with american weaponry when we
love vietnam by the way i don't recall
us leaving all of our weapons there
we have provided them with some 85
billion dollars in american weaponry
apparently
they now have some 16 000 pairs of night
vision goggles which was our chief
special ops advantage over them because
we could see at night and they couldn't
we've left a bunch of attack helicopters
we've left them drones which they will
promptly turn over to china for money
china will then reverse engineer all of
that and now have our military
technology
when joe biden said this wasn't going to
be like saigon i think he meant it was
not going to be as bad as saigon and
turns out that it is significantly worse
than saigon in every conceivable way in
fact as it turns out the biden plan on
foreign policy was to conflate the
withdrawal from saigon the iran hostage
crisis except now with 52 americans with
a thousand americans
the bombing of the usm the bombing of
the u.s marine barracks in in 1982 by
hezbollah lebanon and the iran contra
scandal in which we provided weaponry to
some of america's enemies
so we conflated all of those in a ball
and that's joe biden's preferred foreign
policy here was joe biden july 8th
saying this would not be like saigon do
you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling none whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken the taliban is
not the south of the north vietnamese
army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's gonna be no circumstance where
you see people being lifted off the roof
of a embassy in the of the united states
from afghanistan it is not at all
comfortable
not comparable in the slightest
according to joe biden not at all
okay but let's fast forward a little bit
so you fast forward literally a month so
it wasn't gonna be like saigon now the
taliban has taken over the country
completely
right and joe biden went on national
television august 17th and he said you
know what the buck stops with me it's
actually august 16th the buck stops with
me he says we can't take more casualties
the reason we're leaving is because we
can't take more casualties note we had
zero american combat casualties from
february 2020 until today today we had
12.
minimum thanks to joe biden here was joe
biden just about a week ago august 16th
i am president of the united states of
america
and the buck stops with me
i'm deeply saddened by the facts we now
face
but i do not regret my decision to end
america's warfighting in afghanistan and
maintain
a laser focus on our counter-terrorism
missions there and other parts of the
world i cannot and will not ask our
troops to fight on endlessly another in
another country's civil war
taking casualties
suffering life-shattering injuries
leaving families broken by grief and
loss
families broken by grief and loss
families how many like 12 minimum today
remember zero combat casualties from
february 2020 to now 12 today
thank you joe biden but don't worry he
was championing his own incredible
withdrawal a week and a half ago
he uh went on national television with
george stephanopoulos and he said listen
nobody has died in this evacuation and
then he proceeded to knock on wood i kid
you not
this was joe biden august 18th
still a lot of pandemonium outside the
airport well there is but look
but no one's being killed right now god
forgive me for if i'm wrong about that
but no one's being killed right now
that was august 18th it is now august
26th that is an eight-day gap
no one is being killed right now by the
way when he said no one was being killed
that was precisely two days after
afghans attempting to escape the country
ahead of the taliban were holding on to
the wheel wells of c-17s and following
thousands of feet to their death so he
was lying then
now of course he looks like the
ridiculous buffoon because he is a
ridiculous buffoon
we can look forward to hearing from this
ridiculous buffoon in approximately half
an hour here when he proceeds to put
down his oatmeal
say a few words into camera and then
leave and allow gensake to clean up his
mess
shensaki is now the biden
administration's night nurse
the president craps the bed and gensake
attempts to clean it up unfortunately
the crapping of the bed is not just the
president making a mess of himself it's
him making a mess of the entire country
it's him getting americans killed it's
many americans are going to die not just
the ones who died today
we're going to see hundreds of americans
in deathly peril and tens of thousands
of afghan allies in deadly peril thanks
to joe biden thanks to this idiotic
buffoon
who promised you it would not end like
this who promised you that while
simultaneously withdrawing america from
bagram air base while simultaneously
withdrawing all close air support for
the afghan military while allowing the
taliban to take tens of billions of
dollars of american military equipment
while drawing all american contractors
who are servicing the afghan warplanes
that guy was making you promises and he
violated every one of those promises and
now he's put american soldiers in harm's
way working at the behest of the taliban
that is what this joke of a human being
has done he's been a joke for his entire
career now he's just an adult's joke
that is the only difference between joe
biden of 10 years ago and joe biden now
then he was just a joke now he's an
adult joke but make no mistake what is
happening right now is not a result of
joe biden being mentally incompetent it
is a result of joe biden being plain
incompetent
he made this call he didn't make this
call because he's senile he made this
call because he has been dead wrong on
every major foreign policy issue in his
entire career going all the way back to
vietnam
and you and the media lied about it and
you and the media got him elected
but at least there are no mean tweets
just more dead americans
coming up we'll get into more ridiculous
things said by the biden administration
over the course of the last week don't
forget what they told you just days ago
they were lying then they're lying now
is the bench bureau show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show so the cut and run strategy is
beginning those explosions that i
mentioned earlier the latest explosions
from kabul apparently they're controlled
demolitions we're now destroying the
equipment that we have at kabul
international airport matt zeller
formerly of the cia cnn contributor he
says if that's the case we are
absolutely leaving and soon
which of course is no shock the
president treats the taliban the same
way that he treats the press every time
something rough happens he cuts and runs
but
recall that five seconds ago they were
bragging about this this is a masterful
operation according to joe biden and
company
i mean joe biden and company they've
been lying the entire way they've been
lying the entire way
you recall that just about a week ago on
august 18th the president said we
wouldn't be leaving our afghan allies
behind no way no how we were going to be
taking those people with us we weren't
going to leave them there to the
predations of the taliban certainly we
probably wouldn't like you know give the
taliban a full list of everyone who
wanted to get out so they could go kill
them probably wouldn't do this august
18th with george stephanopoulos
all troops are supposed to be out by
august 31st
even if americans and our afghan allies
are still trying to get out they're
going to leave we're going to do
everything in our power to get all
americans out and our allies out they're
all going to get out
also two days later he said don't worry
we're not leaving americans behind no
way no how we're not going to leave
americans behind guys
let me be clear
any american who wants to come home
we will get you home
nope
not true that is a lie it was a lie at
the time it is a lie now
so he said wouldn't leave our afghan
allies behind doesn't talk about them
anymore they're screwed
he says uh we are not going to leave
americans behind that's not true
anymore that they're screwed as well the
people who are left there
they're likely simply to become
bargaining chips basically whoever isis
catches they will take hostage and then
murder whoever al-qaeda catches they
will take hostage and then murder
whoever the taliban catches they will
probably take hostage and then attempt
to seek a bribe from the united states
that's likely the way that this goes
that same day august 20th joe biden said
don't worry al qaeda is not in
afghanistan
and how many lies i mean
remember that time that they used to
fact-check trump like every five seconds
they have daniel dale it was a font head
of lies
and then you just spew out all the
things that trump had said that were
misconstrued or wrong or false and it
was just it was a fire hose of lies and
daniel dale made his w where's daniel
dale when you need him
he's probably baking a cake in the back
or something
here is a here's joe biden explaining
that al qaeda is not in afghanistan as
of august 20th you will notice that the
haqqani network which is an al-qaeda
offshoot is now providing all of the
security in kabul security by the way so
great that they allowed two suicide
bombers to walk into the middle of
american areas and blow themselves up
here was the president of the united
states just over a week ago
let's put this thing in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al qaeda gone
we went to afghanistan for the express
purpose of getting rid of al qaeda in
afghanistan as well as as well as
getting osama bin laden and we did
we did we i've noticed some terrorists
in afghanistan i don't know if you
noticed them killing americans today but
i've noticed some members of al-qaeda
and lots of members of isis-k
again which is the
also that same day joe biden said this
is six days ago that any attack on our
forces would be met with a swift and
forceful response well
it's been how many hours since these
bombings
seven eight hours since these bombings
have you noticed a swift and forceful
response from the president of the
united states i haven't here he was
august 20th we made clear to the taliban
that any attack
any attack on our forces or disruption
of our operations at the airport will be
met with swift and forceful response
a swift and forceful response now notice
he did try to contain that to the
taliban so he said well if the taliban
does it then there will be a swift and
forceful response but you know if it's
somebody else can you really put that on
the taliban that's not fair i mean guys
that's not fair
yeah but it didn't end there the lies
didn't end there fast forward two days
joe biden was asked at a press
conference about isis and about isis's
presence in uh in afghanistan and uh joe
biden's response was to daughter away
do you just toddle away
gotta get down to the uh to the
commissary where they're serving cream
of wheat this evening this is august
22nd just four days ago
that americans face now
um well bye catch him later apparently
nothing to see here i mean after all
why would we worry about isis
but the good news was that the following
day joe biden said in front of the
american public that the airport was was
getting safer we have increased our
rational access to to kabul we have
expanded our safe zone around the
airport again this is august 22nd
today is august 26th so this was four
days ago
we have a constantly uh
how can i say it
increased
rational access to the airport
where more folk can get there more
safely it's still a dangerous operation
but i don't want to go into the detail
of how we're doing that i think you're
going to see they're going to get out
number two we have made a number of
changes including extending
access around the airport and the safe
zone so everything is great he was
saying that four days ago we expanded
the safe zone guys now in reality we
didn't really expand the safe zone all
we did was just hand over security to
the taliban who again have done a
stellar job with security a shockingly
good job with security
now of course it gets even worse and
we'll get to more of the biden
administration's lies about this in just
one second first let's talk for a second
about the fact that your energy could be
lagging i know it's a really really
depressing time it's depressing for me
it's depressing for everybody and as you
get older you tend to feel a little bit
less energetic than you used to anyway
it can be overwhelming to perform at
your best as you age yeah career family
staying in shape life can get stressful
you start to slow down maybe you're not
present when you want to be to perform
at your best physically and mentally you
can't let age be you this is where m
drive can help m drive is the daily
supplement for driven men who don't want
to slow down who refuse to be tired
every day who want to be the best at
what they do it's packed with clinically
tested ingredients that support healthy
testosterone levels while helping you
lose weight and stay lean added vitamins
and nutrients reduce stress and boost
your drive so you can perform at your
best find it at walgreens and other
retailers or visit mdrive4men.com get 20
off your first order with promo code ben
they have free shipping and a 60-day
money-back guarantee so you have nothing
to lose m drive it's not for everyone
it's for the driven
mdrive4men.com promo code ben again that
is the letter m
driveformen.com promo code ben
mdrive4men.com
promo code ben go check them out right
now free shipping 60 day money back
guarantee so give it a try all right so
didn't you stop there
then the biden administration by a
couple of days ago they were declaring
that everything was hunky-dory
everything this was a stellar mission
so just a few days ago jensaki was
confronted by peter ducey who said i've
noticed that many americans are stranded
in kabul and shenzaki said no how dare
you no americans are stranded in kabul
to which the thousands of americans
stranded in kabul said
here was shinseki again it is now august
26th i keep mentioning the date because
i think it's important for you to know
how recently they were lying to you this
was three days ago
does the person have a sense that most
of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no americans
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i set when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home okay
so um they're doing that
you may have noticed that they are
stranding americans in afghanistan right
they're just going to leave them there
and you notice that they're also playing
this little semantic game where they say
well you know they probably want to stay
there right this is something that you
had the ambassador to afghanistan say he
said you know we've been warning them
for months they should get out oh were
you because i recognize that as of one
month ago you were saying that clearly
the country was not going to fall to the
taliban so there's that but now the idea
is that if you're in afghanistan it's
your fault gang it is your own fault
okay august 24th again two days ago two
days ago jens hockey from the white
house press room announced that this had
actually been a massive unprecedented
success because we'd evacuated so many
people
just as it was a massive unprecedented
success when the captain of the titanic
steered the boat directly into an
iceberg except this time it was the
biden administration
overtly and purposefully steering the
boat into an iceberg and then as the
boat began to sink
getting some people onto the lifeboats
and then declaring they'd done a
wonderful job they'd set a new world
record in a number of people that had
been moved from a giant ship onto a
lifeboat sure there were a bunch of
people over here drowning and sure it
was their fault that the ship had hit
the iceberg in the first place but
can't you recognize when something is
going right here is jen saki explaining
this was all a massive success
i would say that this is now on track
peter to be the largest airlift in u.s
history
so and that is
bringing american citizens out it is
bringing our afghan partners out it is
bringing allies out
so no i would not say that is anything
but a success it's nothing but a success
nothing but a success it's a massive
unprecedented success
by the way
the dnc actually put out a full-on press
release yesterday suggesting this
it said quote
president biden defies expectations
again delivers results in afghanistan
president biden has defied expectations
and exceeded even his own
administration's goal in successfully
ramping up evacuations from afghanistan
not only has president biden evacuated
nearly 60 000 people from kabul with no
american casualties with no american
casualties
this was uh two days ago
but he has taken the steps necessary to
finally end a 20-year long war
and um
he did it man he did it senator chris
murphy in fact it didn't take two weeks
to evacuate 50 000 it took 10 days
unbelievable ugh the genius the
unprecedented genius of joe biden
okay well yesterday literally yesterday
tony blinken the secretary of state he
said here's the thing the people we can
truly rely on and the people we're going
to rely on are the taliban they're going
to be working with us they're our new
best they're there are new besties with
testes we're going to be hanging with
them and they say that you know sure
we're going to leave august 31st ensure
they're going to be americans they get
left behind but the taliban will help us
pass august 31st this was yesterday
we're on track to complete our mission
by august 31st provided the taliban
continue to cooperate and there are no
disruptions to this effort
the president has also asked for
contingency plans in case he determines
that we must remain in the country past
that date
but let me be crystal clear about this
there is no deadline
on our work to help any remaining
american citizens who decide they want
to leave to do so
along with the many afghans who have
stood by us over these many years and
want to leave and have been unable to do
so
that effort will continue every day
every day
for the rest of their lives
because they're going to be stuck there
for quite a while or they're going to be
dead so those are the two choices
anthony blinken saying you know isn't it
just wonderful how much we can rely on
the taliban and uh then today the
taliban went through a couple of suicide
bombers and we now have 12 dead marines
so really really well done
so do you believe them now are you gonna
believe joe biden whatever he tells you
in the next 15 minutes or so when he's
supposed to speak
are you gonna be waiting with bated
breath to see what lies he tells you and
then the media parrot those lies because
we have yet to hear a true thing come
from this administration for the past
six months on this topic or presumably
many others
we'll continue in just one second
talking to jason killmeyer former chief
of staff of global defense security and
justice at deloitte first let us talk
about the fact that you need to keep
your home safe i rely on ring security
with my ring alarm security system i'm
much more at ease when i'm on the road
or away from home my ring alarm equals
peace of mind protect your home with
ring alarm ring alarm is a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer go to
ring.com ben it is the perfect way to
start your ring experience keep an eye
on every corner of your house with
indoor and outdoor cams see what's
happening directly from your phone i
didn't realize how easy the ring alarm
was to install i was able to install it
myself when we moved from california to
florida first thing my wife said get the
ring devices put them on the house we
did we feel a lot safer i can check in
anytime from anywhere and find out
exactly what my kiddos are doing protect
your home anytime from anywhere with
ring alarm as well go to ring.com for a
special offer on a ring alarm security
kit today you can build a system that's
right for your home have it up and
running in just minutes that's ring.com
ben ring.com ben go check them out once
more ring.com for a special offer on
that ring alarm security kit today
already coming up we'll be joined by
jason killmeyer he has a recent piece
over at daley wire on all of the dangers
that we now face thanks to joe biden's
failures in afghanistan this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show on a horrific day in america the
worst foreign policy day i can remember
in my lifetime joining us on the line to
discuss is jason killmeyer former chief
of staff of global defense security and
justice at deloitte consulting llp jason
thanks so much for joining the show
appreciate it
ben thanks for having me so as you watch
this unfold first of all your general
thoughts on the level of battery this is
historically speaking i can't think of a
comparison in my lifetime uh it's it's
astonishing
yeah ben i saw that you tweeted about
that today right too and so each of
these historical analogies are just as
this unfolds they're paling in
comparison and i'm going to venture
another one here that i think will put
this in some perspective too and it's
not
uh saigon it's not beiru it's kabul 1996
25 years ago next month
the taliban rolled into the capital city
of afghanistan for the first time
and like then we mischaracterized and
misunderstood the group
like then we underestimated the ripple
effects for the world
uh like then a secretary of state quite
frankly made statements unmoored from
the reality we're seeing on our our
televisions and like then a democratic
president assured us
that they could keep us safe by taking
pot shots from the air and and i think
they have zero credibility
yeah jason when you look at this
unfolding and it seems like every hour
brings another bad headline so we've
seen obviously uh the devastating
the devastating murder of of 12 american
marines presumably many more are our
possible deaths because we have a bunch
of people in critical condition as well
and we're now hearing the headline that
the american military is uh detonating a
bunch of our equipment at kabul
international airport in preparation for
leaving uh we've also heard from the
head of centcom who has said that the
taliban are providing a security we have
no clue whether they simply let in the
suicide bombers but we are doing that
and not only that i think what is the
the secondary crazy story of the day
apparently we handed the taliban a full
list
of everybody who wanted to get out
which is a kill list i mean that's
everyone that the taliban would like to
kill
yeah and ben each of those things
in a different perspective would seem
unbelievable to us
um and what i'll argue is they are
rational when you accept as the biden
administration has
that we are going to not only sacrifice
all credibility but expose ourselves
give up all of our leverage and trust
our security to a hostile foreign
government from that perspective
entirely rational and i think there's a
missing element here which is
we are still thinking about this as a
transition as a crisis no no there is
one fewer u.s ally and there is one new
adversary that is a taliban government
either unable or unwilling to restrain
terrorism we've seen this movie before
and and that's i think what what is is
so amazing about all of this is we are
currently having an administration
openly tell us that the taliban is going
to protect us from terrorism within a
week of saying that we have massive
bombings at the kabul international
airport killing a large number of
americans the most americans killed in
afghanistan in one incident since 2011
and it's not as though we hadn't seen
that movie before we did see that movie
before when we said the taliban should
get control of terror and they proceeded
to allow osama bin laden to reside in
their country and create a safe haven
for the attacks on the on the u.s
embassies in kenya and tanzania and the
uss cole and then finally september 11.
so why do we think that the script is
going to be any different this time
other than just pure delusion
yeah i think that there is a lot of
wishful thinking when we hear statements
and not just from american but some
other western leaders about how we'll be
able to induce the taliban towards
certain behavior or that their
legitimacy as a government is on the
line those are people speaking as if we
didn't just lose in a stunning fashion
and those are people who don't realize
and think about this is going to sound
like a weird phrase we have now four
decades we're in our fourth decade of
the taliban is a political movement we
have decades of evidence
of who they are
and how they'll behave and the approach
that this administration is promising as
it relates to an over the horizon
capability wholly insufficient to the
threat
so let's talk for a second about the
long-term ramifications of all of this
if you're a terrorist out there the u.s
looks exactly like it looked in 1999 it
just looks like a paper tiger as osama
bin laden one suggested it looks as
though we are willing to throw our
allies directly under the bus to put
them directly in the line of fire uh
that we are willing to put our own
soldiers in the line of fire in an
attempt to surrender unbelievably enough
uh and it looks as though you know
anybody who trusts us is likely to get
screwed they saw an article in the new
york times today saying the israelis
haven't been sharing intelligence with
the biden administration all i could
think is why in the world would they
given what they've just seen in
afghanistan
yeah i think right so there's there's
the immediate point which is we talk
about needing to leave afghanistan to
free us up to engage in these great
power politics it's this imagined
cleaner sort of great east asia
you know move these many carriers here
and get back to that type of statecraft
the reality is our lack of resolve here
will make that harder but even beyond
that
it isn't those powers in asia who change
the skyline of new york city
militant islam gets a vote and it has in
syria iraq afghanistan and conflicts
around the world and i'm afraid we're
going to have to relearn that lesson
well i really appreciate the time with
jason kilmeir former chief of staff of
global defense security and justice at
deloitte consulting llp i appreciate the
time jason
thanks ben alrighty meanwhile again the
update is that we have at least 12
troops killed 15 wounded overall 140
people have been wounded 60 dead overall
we still don't have a count on how many
of those people were american citizens
or green card holders it is a full-scale
disaster over a kabul airport and it is
unclear what the plan is so in
approximately five minutes here we're
going to hear from the president of the
united states who's going to inform us i
mean we've been told all of this was
according to plan right we were told
that it was according to plan
the plan we had contingency plans upon
contingency plans according to this
administration it was all according to
the plan and nothing went wrong it was
one of the best operations in american
history an operation that completely
relied on the taliban for security
abandoned bagram air base completely
destroyed the afghan military from
within handed over 38 million people to
the tender mercies of the taliban gave
the taliban a list of all the people
they should kill because they were
allied with us it's gone great it's
going great and i can't wait i for one
cannot wait to hear from the adult
president of the united states about how
it's going to get even better from here
now here's my prediction for what the
president says and we'll evaluate how
well i did tomorrow on this show i
predicted the president of the united
states is going to say oh yeah we'll go
after the people who did this but it
wasn't the taliban it was isis so we'll
you know we'll take our time we'll find
those people we'll go after them the way
we did osama bin laden which he opposed
then he'll say this just shows why we
need to get out and we need to get out
fast because otherwise our troops are at
risk every failure is more of an excuse
for his own failure
you watch and the straw man will be that
if we didn't get out if we hadn't gotten
out the way that he got out
then this would have been the ultimate
result except much much larger that will
be his bloody-minded idiotic excuse
we'll see how many americans are willing
to buy that given the fact that we're
about to leave thousands of americans
stranded in kabul plus hundreds of
thousands of people who allied with us
against the taliban in the first place
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
you